[Music]
on this saturday night turbulent travel
the confusion over canada's revamped
restrictions this whole thing has been a
roller coaster plus the canadian
national team stuck in south africa
finally secures away home omicron in
ontario there might be a greater risk
for reinfection the province's push to
increase immunity plus rare charges the
parents of a school shooting suspect
appear in court
and a singer turns by receives france's
highest honor
[Music]
global national with robin gill
good evening and thank you for joining
us confusion and frustration are growing
tonight over canada's new pandemic
travel rules the measures are meant to
slow the spread of the new potentially
more transmissible variant but they're
also causing chaos for some canadians
arriving home even after short trips out
of the country jeff semple explains in
our top story tonight
passengers arrive at pearson
international airport unsure what to
expect i'm kind of confused because
there's a lot of things that you have to
do since the discovery of the ominous
omicron variant canada has introduced a
flurry of new travel restrictions the
government just released these flow
charts outlining how the rules apply
differently depending on the country and
how long you're away rules even canada's
top doctor admitted are confusing
basically the requirements
if you're from
it's quite complicated i think we're
going to have to put up some tools on
the website but not everyone is laughing
this whole thing has been a roller
coaster two of sue goddard's daughters
traveled to south africa in november for
a field hockey championship but after
omicron the event was cancelled and the
team booked a trip home through germany
canadians arriving from southern africa
are required to produce one negative
covid test before leaving and another in
the third country on route but because
the team wasn't clearing customs in
germany they were told their test
wouldn't count and they weren't allowed
to travel on to canada mental health
wise for the team it's i'm the honest
it's been quite tough
after two weeks stranded in south africa
lobbying the government the team just
received an exemption and will be
allowed to return to canada next week oh
my god we can't wait to see you but
others aren't so lucky we were totally
blindsided this alberta couple took a
quick trip to the united states canada
does not require a negative test from
travelers to the us for less than 72
hours but they're still required to
upload their vaccine certificates to the
arrive can website or smartphone app and
we didn't have that
we didn't know what it was we didn't
know what it was as a result even though
they've been triple vaxxed they're now
forced to quarantine for two weeks the
communication that has not been very
clear that's one thing and and also
inconsistent this business tourism
expert expects the result will be
another blow for the beleaguered travel
industry not because fully vaccinated
canadians are afraid of getting sick but
because they're afraid of becoming
stranded abroad
jeff semple global news toronto
for more clarification on what you need
to know before you head to the airport
let's go to mercedes stephenson in
ottawa mercedes you sat down with
canada's transport minister this week on
the west block
robin many countries have introduced
additional border measures to try and
stop the spread of the emerging omicron
variant and canada is no exception
ottawa announced a travel ban for
foreign nationals from 10 african
countries where the new variant was
first identified in addition mandatory
covet 19 tests upon arrival to canada
were reintroduced for travelers from all
destinations except the united states
now even fully vaccinated people have to
quarantine until they receive the result
of their arrival test the testing
requirement has created a lot of concern
and confusion including where the tests
will be administered and what happens to
canadians who land in one city but need
to transit and take a connecting flight
to get home
this week on the west block we sit down
with transportation minister omar
algabra to get some clarity on the rules
and what they mean for you ahead of the
busy holiday travel season i asked the
minister where the tests will be given
for those who have a connecting flight
and who will be quarantining where
so
if you are coming from any of those 10
countries you are tested upon arrival
wherever you arrive and you're expected
to stay at a hotel wherever you arrive
however if you're arriving from anywhere
else in the world from rome for example
you will be tested if you land in
toronto and then you'll be allowed to go
to vancouver and quarantine at home for
a day or two until your test results are
out while travelers from the united
states are exempt from canada's new
rules the u.s is not extending the same
exception to canada anyone entering the
u.s must bring a negative covid antigen
test taken within the last 24 hours
that's raised questions about whether
canada should harmonize policies with
the u.s or continue to allow people in
with a three-day old test we still
require fully vaccinated we only allow
you as travelers who are fully
vaccinated into canada and we have
random mandatory testing at the border
the us doesn't have mandatory testing at
their own borders so we have because we
have several layers of protection we'll
bring you our full interview on the new
travel rules on the west block robin
mercedes stephenson in ottawa and you
can watch the west spot tomorrow right
here on global
for a second straight day ontario is
reporting more than a thousand yukova 19
cases today's total is the highest in a
single day since may 29th most of those
cases are believed to be the delta
variant but the new omicron variant is
spreading the wh says it's now in 38
countries including canada as of today
11 cases of omicron have been reported
in ontario there are other potential
infections currently under investigation
and as brittany rosen reports it's
prompted a push for more vaccinations in
the province
omicron may be on a similar trajectory
as other cova 19 variants of concern as
more cases arise across the country yet
the severity of its path is still mostly
unknown there's some very very early
data coming out of south africa that we
still have to be
open-minded to but i also appreciate
that it's early data and we still have
to be somewhat skeptical but there might
be a greater risk for re-infection
after first being detected in ottawa
november 28th cases of omicron are
popping up elsewhere in ontario
including a child under 12 in york
region north of toronto the variant is
now also in quebec alberta and british
columbia dr suman chakrabarti says still
there is no reason to be alarmed at this
point in time this is not the same as
the situation when when the uk variant
or alpha came out i understand the
concern i don't think we need to panic
and i definitely don't think that we
need to go back into the broad lockdown
restriction situations that we had a
year ago yet the response to omicron has
been nimble travel restrictions have
already been imposed and ontario has
since expanded eligibility for the third
shot a recommendation recently derived
from nasty
starting on december 13th ontario
residents over 50 will be able to book a
third vaccination alberta has taken
similar steps while quebec is waiting on
the advice of provincial health
officials now we are
eligible for the
booster in december 13 i will go there i
think it's really important because it's
just going to uh be an added safety
measure the new variant is one the other
thing is i am traveling over christmas
and according to ontario's science table
the third shot should no longer be
considered a booster consider this to be
a three dose vaccine now this holds true
for the majority of our population in
the future and already right now dr
peter uni says third doses will play a
major part in increasing immunity to
covid and says everyone who can get one
should
brittany rosen global news
the british government is set to tighten
restrictions on international visitors
as of tuesday all incoming travelers age
12 and above will be required to take a
covid19 test 48 hours before boarding a
flight to the uk
there will also be increased
restrictions on non-british travelers
from nigeria who will have to quarantine
in a hotel for 10 days after arriving as
of today there are at least 160
confirmed omicron cases in the uk
the delta variant is still the dominant
strain in the u.s but there are more
signs of omicron more than two dozen
cases have been reported across 11
states some of those patients recently
traveled but others had no travel
history indicating community spread is
underway so far no hospitalizations have
been reported for those who've tested
positive for the new variant since the
start of the pandemic the u.s has
reached 49 million cova 19 infections
and nearly 790 000 americans have died
the manhunt for the parents of a
15-year-old michigan school shooting
suspect ended early this morning
jennifer and james crumbly were on the
run after being indicted on four counts
of involuntary manslaughter their son
ethan crumbly was arrested earlier this
week accused of murdering four
classmates in a shooting spree the
entire family is now being held at the
same jail as jennifer johnson reports
police say they're looking at who may
have helped the fugitive parents hide
james and jennifer crumbly parents of
accused school shooter 15 year old ethan
crumbly are now behind bars the pair had
evaded police for several hours but were
found hiding in a commercial building in
detroit about 67 kilometers from oxford
clearly somebody helped them into that
location and made it available to them
and it was after it was publicly
announced that there were warrants for
them on friday the parents were charged
with four counts each of involuntary
manslaughter in the deaths of the high
schoolers their son is accused of
killing they have pleaded not guilty the
crumblies are accused of failing to take
ethan home and get counseling the
morning of the tragedy after school
officials showed them a chilling paper
found on the boy's desk the note was a
drawing of a bullet with the following
words above that bullet quote blood
everywhere further down the drawing are
the words quote my life is useless end
quote the prosecutor also accuses the
pair of buying ethan the semi-automatic
gun he allegedly used to kill his
classmates school officials saw the
teenager searching for ammunition on his
phone the day before the shootings his
mother was allegedly contacted by the
school but phone records show she texted
her son lol i'm not mad at you you have
to learn not to get caught i expect
parents and everyone to to have humanity
and to step in
and stop stop a potential tragedy school
shooting at oxford high school
prosecutors say within minutes of the
shootings the mother also texted her son
ethan don't do it the parents attorney
claims they fled the area fearing for
their safety but they took four thousand
dollars out of an atm prompting u.s
marshals to offer a bounty for
information leading to their arrests
this very very tragic incident that
really has touched not just this
community not just the state
you know but this country i mean we're
tired of this i mean this is awful this
was the 28th school shooting in america
so far this year the tragedy has plunged
the small town into despair and fear
a massive vigil for the victims friday
night ended in near panic after someone
fainted and others called for help the
local prosecutor a mother herself is
vowing to help this community heal
promising those who failed to stop this
tragedy will pay
jennifer johnson global news washington
french president emmanuel macron says
several european countries are
considering opening a joint diplomatic
mission in afghanistan during a trip to
qatar macron says the mission would
allow ambassadors to be present in the
country but it would not amount to
recognition of the taliban government
many western countries including canada
closed their embassies in august when
the islamist militant group took control
of the capital macron says security
concerns and several other issues would
need to be resolved before a mission
could be opened
coming up another bc community told to
get out but they're refusing to leave
and darkness descends on antarctica's
summer
[Applause]
residents near indonesia's mount samarou
are fleeing for their lives a powerful
volcanic eruption sent hot ash and gas
down onto villages below at least one
person died from severe burns and more
than 30 others were injured the ash was
so thick and black it completely blocked
out the daylight in some places
the mayor of flood ravaged abbotsford bc
says he can see the light at the end of
the tunnel some residents displaced by
three record-breaking storms are finally
getting back into their homes or what's
left of them and assessing how to move
forward as mike delay reports the flood
waters may be receding but the problems
left behind appear to be multiplying
far north of the flood plains of sumas
prairie and just north of the town of
mission another evacuation order the
fields are flooded the rivers and lakes
far higher than normal but gord mattel
says his house is dry so he's not
leaving do you think that the evacuation
order was
senseless a little bit late i think with
the ground oversaturated the fear of
landslides and road washouts remains
real and rural communities on well water
now have to be concerned with
contamination from sewage and dead
animals the worst of the flood has
passed in many areas but in many ways
the disaster has become more complicated
so what needs to be done around here
a lot
i don't know how they're going to clean
up how is one thing how much is another
the province has begun taking bids on
reconstruction projects but they don't
want to just rebuild bridges and
highways they want them to be engineered
to withstand larger storms in the future
the water came up to about there
residents of the hardest hit areas have
more immediate needs cleaning up their
homes
it just
it smelled like mold it was all damp in
here water levels have gone down over a
half meter in the last 48 hours and more
water was pumped out of sumas prairie
today with no major storms ahead many
evacuation orders are slowly being
lifted
most residents haven't seen their homes
in two weeks what do you do you rebuild
it's one foot in front of the other
we're all here in the same boat so
there's no you know
some people lost more lost less but
our lives changed all of ours right and
another bit of good news the trans
mountain pipeline that's been out of
service since the flooding began is
expected to go back online sunday
the reopening of southern bc will be
gradual bridges and roads have to be
inspected and some of the lowest lying
areas are days or even weeks away from
being fully dry
the recovery won't be easy
but at least it's begun
microlight global news abbotsford bc
still ahead can blockchain unblock the
supply chain issue
for some industries supply chain
disruptions have created a logistical
nightmare especially ahead of the
holidays but the problem has paved the
way for cutting edge canadian solutions
and gaviola has more on those homegrown
innovations
this is going to be the most wonderful
holiday ever few companies have
navigated supply chain snafus as well as
retail giant walmart its deep pockets
allowed it to do things like charter its
own ships but at the heart of its
strategy is a cutting edge solution made
in canada due to the virtue of what the
way we have designed
walmart never stopped so we were part of
the essential services toronto based dlt
labs helped walmart canada implement and
manage its massive supply chain invoice
and payment platform
using blockchain the technology that
underpins cryptocurrencies like bitcoin
think of this digital ledger as a way to
automate transactions and data points
using gps and the internet of things to
track everything from shipping routes
and delays to truck refrigeration
temperatures for food and keep it
securely on one platform it was up and
running just days before the pandemic
shut the world down the timing was
perfect because of course supply chains
ended up being
horrendously stressed supply chain
experts say blockchain technology's high
cost means it's not the right solution
for every business i wouldn't say it's
adaptable to just everybody as of yet
but it's definitely an emerging
technology that we're keeping our eye
closely on
one homegrown solution that's emerged
during covid is a shift to local
producers which lessens dependence on
supply chains we're finding that one of
the best things we can do is
because of the high cost of freight and
because of the instability and strong
delays in the supply chain is to find as
many great manufacturers in canada and
the united states as we can canadian
manufacturing climbed to a seven-month
high in october though it remains to be
seen if this is a lasting trend perhaps
the most important lesson learned from
the supply chain chaos is that having a
plan b and c
is no longer optional
ann gaviola global news toronto
up next an american in paris and what
she did for france
at this time of year antarctica
experiences 24 hours of sunlight but for
a few moments today there was a total
solar eclipse it's a rare sight over the
southernmost continent and it's the only
place on the planet the moon completely
blocked the sun the next total solar
eclipse over antarctica won't happen
until 2039
josephine baker may not be a household
name in canada but she is in france born
in america the dancer and singer spent
much of her career in europe and during
the second world war her performances
were a cover for her work as a spy
this week she was given a rare honor
reserved for french national heroes
crystal gomezing explains
an icon of the 20s with a deep love for
france admiration reciprocated by
millions
french president emmanuel macron praised
josephine baker saying she did not
defend a skin color she carried a
certain idea of human kind and fought
for the freedom of all
[Music]
at a rare ceremony earlier this week in
paris a coffin was carried into the
famed pantheon not holding remains but
soil from the countries that shaped
baker 46 years after she passed away
baker is only the sixth woman to be
honored with a tomb in the pantheon's
mausoleum and the first black woman
baker left america in her hometown of st
louis missouri at 19
looking for opportunities as a dancer it
was in france where she rose to fame as
one of the headliners at the renowned
foley bergere in paris at baker's
namesake hotel no one's surprised she
was invited into the crypt with the
likes of marie curie and voltaire
it shows that french culture is opening
up to things different from literature
or only certain types of art
cabaret gave baker and france an edge
during the war in 1940 baker pivoted
from stage siren to spy using her
performances around europe to collect
information for the french resistance
[Music]
she was just mom
baker adopted 12 children
as a mother she was very simple he says
as soon as she got home it was over she
dropped her luggage she cooked spaghetti
and stuff
a mother a spy a performer and years
later a passionate civil rights advocate
even speaking at the 1963 march on
washington
baker's strength determination and grace
now cemented in history with one of the
highest honors in france
crystal gamansen global news
london
what a lovely story and that is global
national for this saturday night i'm
robin gill tonight your canada is the
waves crashing on the shores of northern
bay in newfoundland and labrador we'd
love to see your corner of the country
so please keep sending your photos to
viewers at globalnational.com
thank you for watching and i'll see you
back here tomorrow have a great night
[Music]
you